julian grow at will mushrooms will grow too willingly
and nato grow
minute big fashion and manager is mine
david copeland in mexico
lothar quast the world
yes then i wouldn't i would
n't get vaccinated for now yes definitely
i want to get vaccinated
so alone  already because of where parents were also
visiting remains the touch
mac studies is definitely
to finish the panini quickly and so that
cases can do more things that are fun again if all this is
approved then I will trust you too yes
I would because I every
assess the risk of vaccination as lower than
not without infecting your own western pomeranian
says i think to myself what so if if there is
it is good that you protect the others
that you protect yourself
i would wait that i know what i
can do and what the consequences are  fell out of
old paper then you can see
your way from ireland in front of valentin next to
who is looking now no one can foresee
now there are no long-term studies
my concerns are that
maybe in two years after
the vaccination with elephant's foot I have no
idea what you've got no idea what because he knows it's
actually just a [ __ ] is
actually just about the money as a doctor
express alexion skateboard car end
stunned on evaluation from  companies
like modern construction and
astrazeneca us group get along
on the radio there are
well we assume already approved
that's just normal
but most are very wild and
maybe a third about
depending on the info gets a fever
mostly that's limited to just a few hours
and then it's fine again the next day
the concerns are that there are of
course no studies on
long-term consequences and most
side effects occur immediately after the
vaccination within hours or
late is the act what comes afterwards
is very very rare this  interplay
over seven years to get the active ingredient healthy
now it doesn't even take three
or four months to produce it or every
year it
's missing at some point it's
all about the money
the trophies of the plant in half a child
under 15 is firstly because there
is not enough money little interest and
vaccines not enough interest  they
have money of
course there is money involved
the companies want to
earn something they already earn an
awful lot from it from state
funds or from other large
foundations and private investors
huge companies bring vaccine production
there flows of course it’s all about the money
[music]
before the crown  at aus crysis fir sech
eens happy come global problem the
world health organization action there
as one of the top ten world wild web
last one ries and for that is the
christoph mess information technology
nations is the temple
that is biologically unthinkable that
I do that now  genetic material missed what's going on
there makes that is unimaginable
knockout  mplett on so i can on
women i often have no own opinion
microchip
rowling be so before your sports
information post sexy single world
frist jack bender informations posted by way
to the theory although for axel research
then the touch backup climate expert
green asks that will main  legally
between fiction discovers even labadia
but dedicate the action speedcore texan